we learned yesterday that Republican
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
held up the passage of the coronavirus
stimulus bill that the Senate ultimately
approved and the house is presumably
going to approve today and maybe by the
time you listen to this they already
have Mitch McConnell held it up for an
additional unnecessary 10 days now I
would actually go even further and I
said this before and in fact now the
pandemic response a playbook that was
left behind for the Trump administration
by the Obama administration says the
same thing they should have started
working on the stimulus package weeks
ago probably even even a couple of
months ago ahead of the curve starting
to climb instead of creating this panic
behind always behind the curve situation
which ultimately is what developed but
we've long lost that battle let's forget
about that what we know is that in
practice Mitch McConnell could have
moved this thing through the Senate far
faster than he did the conservative
assessment is that there were 10
unnecessary days of delay here Senate
agrees goes to the house presumably for
a vote today
so yesterday Mitch McConnell does a
press conference about the bill first
question comes from a female reporter
and it's a very good question which
we'll get to in a second Mitch McConnell
puts this dumb-looking expression on his
face and then he responds by saying to
her do you work here
take a look at the clip understanding
that of course this is a crisis and time
is of the essence this vote began and
the public had not yet seen the bill
lobbyists had seen the bill and none of
the debate had been held in public there
is virtually no public debate on what
looks to be the largest bill in American
history can you explain why that was and
should the public have had more time to
understand what this bill is that is
meant to help them the American people
do you work here she correctly points
out you voted the bill wasn't made
public lobbyists I the public wasn't
able to actually see any of the debate
because the debate wasn't public the
public wasn't able to look at the bill
and then
lawmakers and say hey what about this
what about that which is part of the
system that we have where the public
gets that weigh in on what it is that is
going to be passed ten days of a delay
and still without the public debate
without the time during which the bill
could have been reviewed no opportunity
for the public to even attempt to lobby
their members of Congress and Mitch
McConnell's answer is do you work here
this guy who ran the impeachment
hearings like a clown show I mean really
a kangaroo court the same guy who
delayed delayed delayed and now
Americans maybe in three weeks
some Americans will start getting a
$1,200 check instead of being days away
if Mitch McConnell had gotten this done
10 days ago he's asked a real
substantive question and his reaction is
do you work here we've got to get that
seat back guys we've we have to remove
Mitch McConnell there is an opponent
Mitch McConnell has an opponent Ami
McGrath running against him former
Marine fighter pilot was a democratic
congressional nominee back in 2018 this
is this could be a fight it's going to
be an uphill battle there are recent
polls that show they are running close
we know that when you have the power of
incumbency once that sweet sweet
Republican National money starts pouring
in for Mitch McConnell it's gonna be an
uphill battle for Ami McGrath I don't
pretend it's going to be anything
otherwise but to January polls have it
very close and in the end we have a real
opportunity here not just to remove any
Republican senator and turn the seat
blue not just the opportunity to remove
the Senate Majority Leader by turning a
seat blue we have the opportunity to
remove what has been what who the person
who has been one of the most effective
Republican tools and I don't mean tool
you know the as an ad hominem he has
been a tool of the Republican Party
effectively doing work for them for a
very very long time and as I've said
before I always want to have clarity
when I bring this up when I say Mitch
McConnell has been incredibly successful
it's doing all things I find disgusting
but when you look at Mitch McConnell's
role in holding up the Merrick garland
Supreme Court nominee nomination
in Barack Obama leading to Donald Trump
getting to put Neil Gorsuch on the court
if you're a Republican that's a massive
accomplishment look at all of the judges
that Mitch McConnell has successfully
sort of shepherded through Senate
confirmation and gotten installed in
lifetime positions allowing Donald Trump
and Pryor Republicans to mold the
judiciary for decades to come
this is one of the most successful and
efficient operators doing all terrible
things so if you're looking for you know
we don't know exactly what's going to
happen with the virus we don't know when
and how these campaigns including the
Senate campaign presidential etc are
going to resume and in what form but at
a certain point you'll probably be able
to phone bank for Amy McGrath and at a
certain point there still will be these
campaigns being fought one way or the
other this is a good one Mitch McConnell
against Amy McGrath and really working
to see if we can make this a reality it
would be an incredible coup to be able
to remove Mitch McConnell I'm posting
short videos on rizal you can respond to
me directly with your video and then I
can respond to you check it out it's a
very cool platform for short form video
I've been posting there for six weeks
have a bunch of stuff bunch of cool
prompts use the link down in the video
description it's all free I'll see you
on rizal